[Music]
what is the biggest adjustment that you
have right now to being married you are
now married living together with my wife
yes what's the what's the biggest
adjustment you know first of all it's
lovely being married you know because
now I can hit on other women and not
seem creepy and it's like no the beauty
the beautiful thing it's not the
beautiful thing but the thing that I'm
getting adjusted to is for example today
I was eating some salt and vinegar chips
and I like that I like the taste of them
and I okay you know the part of your
finger gets a little crusty with the
salt in vinegars and stuff and then and
I was washing my hands and my wife was
in the kitchen I washed my hands and I
used the towel and I put it back on the
towel rack mm-hmm so my wife without
seeing anything goes back to the towel
rack picks up the towel folds it very
nicely and neatly gives me the biggest
smile and puts it back on the towel rack
and walks away okay
okuu now that's very beautiful that but
I'm telling you as the guy who's been
married 10 years that's gonna change
that's gonna where she's gonna throw the
towel of my space like no but
she's being but I don't know what's
worse is the passive-aggressiveness
worse or is the anger worse of the
anchors were already see so you you
recently moved into a new home tell us
about that it's a lovely home what we
did in the room in our master bedroom
actually which I thought was genius is
we have two televisions in the master
bedroom so when we watch television at
night I watch a television which is my
television with my blu-ray headphones on
so I'm watching golf or SportsCenter
manly things and my wife is watching you
know the fashion stuff and like you know
Project Runway but I am watching this
television with blu-ray headphones and
she's watching her television this
doesn't sound good to me I'm just
telling you I know that right now you
think this sounds good but this is the
time you've got this beautiful wife
you're newly married you're together
yeah in the bedroom and what you're not
even listening to each other and you're
watching separate TV shows this will
divide you over time I think it's a bad
idea it's going to divide us is whether
we should watch sports center or the
Kardashians that's what's gonna end our
marriage Kardashians is pretty good I
know some really lovely seem crazy stuff
so you're gonna you're gonna and these
TVs are side-by-side no there's one
there's I'd be distracted by the other
TV all the time
yeah well I'm not that intelligent so I
just look at colors and I'm looking at
them no this we have one we have one on
the side and we have one in the front so
there's a TV over here the TV over here
and them is a TV on is one TV clearly
the better TV like this see my wives is
better like obviously yeah the one that
looks forward and I have the one that's
I have to watch this
it sounds like you've got an iPhone
hanging on a string and she got
acquiesced too soon yeah no no you were
gonna lose anyway
[Laughter]